c'est aides soignants de 25 ans a
demandé son passeport ici à la mairie de
levier ben il fumait rêve d'amérique
mais pas de n'importe laquelle celle de
certains de nos ancêtres franc comtois
parti là-bas au 19e siècle beaucoup
habitaient cette commune autant connaît
les migrations des habitants de
championnat un messie coutances et le ce
de levier là les etats-unis est restée
plus plus confidentiels est en effet
c'est la rencontre avec les descendants
de ces immigrés partis partis en
amérique qui se profile dans quelques
jours
répondeur sauveur et fraude il y fut
maire rêve aussi de vivre de sa passion
la musique notamment le folk made in
franche-comté jusqu'au bout du texte les
chansons qu'il va partager lors d'un
périple américain
faux lui à new york juste ici ensuite
traversée jusqu'au midwest donc
pennsylvanie oyo indiana l'illinois le
missouri et une redescente en sus par le
tennessee jusqu'au texas
tout a été préparé à la bonne franquette
en prenant contact avec des habitants de
localités comme besançon dans l'indiana
où résident des descendants de francs
comtois son objectif recréer des liens
entre eux et la franche-comté participer
au rayonnement culturel et faire
reconnaître cette diaspora comme un
relais en fait de de la culture et de
l'histoire de la franche comté
voilà il ya une dynamique qui est art
cris et c'est aussi le but de cette
tournée c'est celle là c'est un put être
un ambassadeur
du mas candille quitte le rêve américain
de billy fumée commence demain
et à bien d indiana débat du site
ce commerce missouri